in 2017 Narendra Modi became India's
first prime minister to visit Israel
during the visit India and Israel signed
a series of arms deals that totaled over
2.6 billion dollars
in addition to tech and science steals
that totaled over 40 million which isn't
necessarily unusual considering India is
in fact the biggest buyer of Israeli
arms but it is pretty surprising when
you consider how India didn't even
recognize Israel as a state when it
declared its independence in 1948
instead India allied itself with the
Palestinians so how did India go from
not recognizing Israel as a state to
becoming one of its most important
military allies hey guys I'm sana this
is AJ plus and this Sunday I want to
delve with you into this little-known
history of the relationship between
India and Israel and how capitalism made
India and Israel friends kind of
actually really
[Music]
Indian Israel's relationship begins with
well when Israel was established in 1948
after what Israel calls its war of
independence fought against neighboring
and invading Arab countries following
his victory Israel declared itself a
state and within days and weeks it was
recognized by the United States the USSR
and 19 other countries India which was
fresh off the heels of the bloodiest
partition of the twentieth century
voted against a partition of Palestine
in 1947 and against allowing Israel into
the United Nations in 1949 see India's
concern was twofold it viewed the
partition of Palestine as a colonial
imposition
so its sympathized with Palestinians it
also had good long-standing relations
with Arab countries so upsetting its
regional allies and going against its
own anti colonial principles weren't
things that India was too stoked about
and as journalist Vijay Prashad pointed
out to me India wasn't just a passive
supporter of Palestine India was perhaps
Palestine most devoted or closest ally
PLO chairman Yasser Arafat now India did
eventually recognize the State of Israel
in 1950 but it remained a pretty distant
when it came to diplomatic relations
with the state for instance while it
allowed an Israeli consulate to be
opened in Mumbai that same year it
didn't allow for an embassy in its own
capital Billy India also was a member of
the non-aligned movement which was a
group founded in 1961 of countries that
didn't really want to align with any
power bloc during the Cold War a crucial
part of the non-aligned movement was
support for the Palestinian Liberation
Organization and India was one of the
first non Arab states to recognize the
PLO as the representative of the
Palestinians yes the same PLO that
Israel considered a terrorist
organization
now despite being non-aligned during the
Cold War India did begin to move towards
the Soviet Union while the United States
focused on Pakistan and while India and
Israel were cold on the diplomatic front
Indian and Israeli intelligence services
known as raw and Mossad respectively did
collaborate when security and military
interests intersected so relations
between India and Israel remained like
this until the whole you
collapse of the bipolar world order aka
Soviets out America on top when the
Soviet Union was collapsing and
eventually did dissolve in 1991 India
had to shift its political and economic
direction and that new direction took it
towards the United States after finding
itself in major debt India set out to
economically liberalize in 1991 and that
meant the u.s. had to be a major partner
we'd in this country have to wake up to
the harsh new realities of this world
and as Porsha told me that meant that
India had to forge a relationship with
Israel what the Americans towards the
Indian but if you want a close
relationship with Washington DC you have
to first a make up with Israel in other
words the road to Washington DC had to
go through Tel Aviv so we see the full
establishment of diplomatic ties between
India and Israel in 1992 which included
opening that embassy in Lille finally
and we see that relationship translate
throughout the 90s and 2000's as a
strong military one and four-shot
stresses that the relationship between
India and Israel should be looked at
through the lens of arms deals not
simply a link between Hindu nationalism
and Zionism and it's an arms
relationship that really begins by the
way after India's 1998 nuclear testing
which led the United States to tighten
its relationship with India and impose
sanctions India could no longer access
American arms because of various
amendment against non-proliferation in
the US Congress and in the late 1990s of
course Russian arms manufacturing was
still suffering greatly from the
collapse of the Soviet Union and so here
came the Israelis saying essentially you
know we can provide you with American
quality arm but without the kind of
hypocrisy of the United States
government a 2003 visit by Israeli prime
minister Ariel Sharon to India show the
world how the relationship between the
two countries was evolving publicly and
Modi's 2017 visit to Israel was also
another showing of the right-wing Hindu
nationalist government's commitment to
growing its relationship with Israel
while Prashad doesn't think that the
primary relationship between the two
should be defined in ideological terms
he does say that you can't
ignore the link between Hindu
nationalism and Zionism the current
Hindu right government had an
ideological view that remarkably similar
to that of the Zionist leadership in
Israel which is to say it generally has
woodlands it has a very distorted vision
of security where the idea of terrorism
particularly so-called Islamic terrorism
focuses their attention and both India
and Israel have a huge military presence
in the Kashmir Valley and the
Palestinian territories respectively
think curfews checkpoints protests
crackdowns political prisoners yes lots
in common but despite this India can't
completely pivot towards Israel becoming
a sort of us like a lie in which the
relationship is sacrosanct or
inalienable it has some pretty
significant ideological economic and
political constraints
despite closer relations with Israel
India has overwhelmingly stuck to
principle in its UN General Assembly
voting record but that's also perhaps
because of its own allies and even some
frenemies all of the non-aligned
membership votes against Israel when
these atrocities come up in the UN so
the idea is this India breaks ranks
others may follow but that's far he has
not been able to break rank it is also
held back by membership in the
non-aligned movement and more recently
in the BRICS block this is largely
because Russia China South Africa they
will not come to any kind of pro-israel
voting record from India
additionally India is a big consumer of
oil and countries like Iran Iraq and
Saudi Arabia are among its top suppliers
in other words countries that don't
exactly have the best of relations with
Israel and while Modi's visit to Israel
was treated as somewhat significant in
the media - the symbolism of him being
India's first prime minister to go
nothing to exceptional actually happened
yes a 2.6 billion dollar arms deal was
signed but how significant is that when
India has consistently been the top
consumer of Israeli weapons Prashad also
thinks that the relationship between
India and Israel isn't as strong as many
may like to think he sees it as more
opportune
the next essential as with so much in
the world I'm still governs policy and
if there is an alternative is really
arms industry for India I would and it's
worth noting that India a country of
over 1.3 billion people does have a
diversity of political opinion including
on Israel surprise there are Indian
political movements and parties and of
course every day people who are against
normalization with Israel especially
those on the left of the political
spectrum but with Modi and the Hindu
nationalist government's popularity
still expanding and with an increasingly
hostile border with China it remains to
be seen how off its own traditional path
India's willing to go with Israel when
we usually think about who the
Palestinians call their allies India
isn't the first country that comes to
mind what you guys think did you guys
know about this relationship between
India and Israel and what are some other
relationships other geopolitical
relationships that you want to know
about let us know in the comments and
don't forget to Like share and subscribe
and come back next Sunday when we come
at you with another great video I
promise